battlefield fives war stories focused on
more of the unexplored and unknown parts
of world war two taking inspirations
from lesser-known conflicts and bringing
these stories and exploits to life
through the vignette of a single
individual the value of these stories is
how they present a much more personal
conflict there's no storming the beaches
of Normandy or assault on Stalingrad and
I think this is why the war stories both
in battlefield 1 and battlefield 5
really struck a chord with me
they were impactful in a way that I
didn't expect and told a story that most
modern media hadn't touched upon with
the release of the last tiger I was
thinking about other stories that would
fit the intimate war story formula and
remembered the battle for Castle it's
the only time in the Second World War
where Germany and America allied and
what historical accounts referred to as
the strangest battle of World War two
now I know EA have said that they have
no more plans or war stories in the
future but that shouldn't stop us from
talking about what moments in history
could make impactful transitions into
video games the battle was one of the
final events in the European theater
taking place five days after Hitler's
suicide and only two days before the
unconditional surrender of Germany
although most interestingly it is the
only time in the Second World War where
the forces of the Allies and German
powers would fight alongside each other
Castle itza was claimed as a prison camp
in 1943 with its purpose to house
high-profile French prisoners that were
valuable to the Reich occupants included
renowned tennis player Jean Barra former
Prime Minister's Edouard Daladier and
Paul Renard as well as a number of other
influential French individuals and
Eastern European prisoners that worked
around and maintained the castle after
the SS commander and troops are banned
in the castle the French prisoners took
up arms and attempted to summon aid from
the nearby town of org knowing that if
the SS troops were to return to the
castle they would be executed a
messenger was able to contact Austrian
resistance the head of which was a major
yosef dangle a Verma officer who was
against the Nazi regime and had defied
orders to retreat and instead join the
resistance major gang all travelled to
the nearby town of kufstein where he
surrendered to a US Armored Division led
by a captain John see Jack Lee jr.
presenting the situation to the captain
he pled for aid and a rescue attempt to
free the French prisoners Lee
volunteered to lead the rescue mission
without hesitation immediately earning
permission from the US HQ although
through the common
of rough terrain an unstable bridge men
that Lee would have to leave the bulk of
his armor and reinforcements behind and
in the end he was forced to head to the
castle with only his Sherman tank 14
American soldiers major Kangol his
driver and a truck carrying 10 German
artillery man as the combined forces of
the Americans and the ver market arrived
the prisoners now led by an SS officer
they had befriended while he was
recovering from wounds offered a warm
welcome but were rather disappointed in
the small size of the group that had
come to save them knowing that an
attacking force could arrive at any
moment the next morning of forced
numbering between 150 to 200 waffen-ss
opened fire on the castle from the tree
lines with them they bought a flak 88
anti-tank gun which damaged both the
castle and destroyed the Sherman tank
that was providing machine-gun fire as
the day went on the Allied group was
suffering injuries and casualties even
suffering the loss of major Ganga
himself who was killed by a rifle round
while he was attempting to get former
prime minister Reynard to safety as
there was no line of communication for
the castle reinforcements were unaware
of enemy disposition knowing that the
key to victory lay in ensuring those
reinforcements were able to get to the
castle quickly and with up-to-date
information tennis star Bharata offered
to run through the attacking SS dodging
strong points and ambushes to deliver
up-to-date information
miraculously managing to survive and
reach the American reinforcements he
requested a uniform a weapon and
ammunition joining the force as they
made haste to the castle to relieve the
defenders as the occupants the castle
were nearly out of ammunition and
prepared for the enemy force to breach
the walls help finally arrived and a
4:00 p.m. the SS were quickly defeated
by the tanks and infantry of the relief
force resulting in approximately 100 SS
soldiers being taken prisoner only two
days later Germany would formally sign
their unconditional surrender
for his heroic deeds Lee would receive
the Distinguished Service Cross and for
giving his life in the battle Ganga was
honored as an Austrian national hero
even having a street in the nearby Vogel
named in his honor
similar to the current suite of war
stories are recounting this battle
aligns perfectly with the intimacy that
this series already presents and it's a
chance to shed light on another seldom
told story with the same intimacy that
is already present in the series as well
as it being a chance for interesting
characters and intense set pieces
imagine it being told from a multitude
of perspectives
the French prisoner who is unsure of
their future being locked away from the
world the ver mark soldier whose country
is about to lose the war and has to seek
help from the Army they were fighting
against only a few weeks prior the
American soldier having to put aside any
hatred for the enemy for the greater
good and for the safety of the
imprisoned imagine all these individuals
some with extremely polarizing views
experiences and opinions and not only
the war but of each other being thrust
together in an attempt to survive all
under overwhelming odds gameplay why is
a castle it's a war story could include
sections where prisoners are delivering
messages and reinforcements they would
allow stealth and guile and the main
battle could not only provide the
spectacle of a classic battlefield
set-piece with the lack of ammunition
and manpower also playing directly into
battlefield fives attrition system but
players would also be forced to make
every shot count from the position of
the castle walls waiting for
reinforcements to appear on the horizon
I think it's also important to bring
people's attention to the battle itself
as I said before it's about humanity
putting aside their differences for
getting past conflicts and working
together so that they may help those in
need after listening to the recounting
of one of the strangest battles of World
War two I think you can understand why
it would be perfect to be featured as a
war story in battlefield 5 not only is
it a bizarre story but also offers the
opportunity for a deeply personal look
at a part of the second world war with
close-knit groups of people being thrust
together in utterly uncompromising
circumstances considering how unique the
event is it's surprising to see that it
is mostly gone unexplored by modern
media sure of an awesome track off of
sabatons 2016 album The Last Stand if
you found this snippet interesting
though I could only go into so much
detail with the battle so I really
recommend you go read up about it
yourself as it is a fascinating part of
the Second World War but to any other
history enthusiasts with tales to share
I want to know what you think would make
an awesome battlefield war story one
explored events would you'd like to see
explored on the small screen let me know
in the comment section below or find me
on twitter at a regular Dave for now
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one